[Music]
I don't understand sir if you're doing
it with a feminist perspective you are
bringing a particular bias to it but you
also believe in the goal of objective
science so how do you hold those
together I think it's very hard I mean I
think all you can really do is
acknowledge that there can be bias and
see if there are ways of dealing with it
I mean I think particularly when you're
in my area when when you're looking at
brain activity in different groups we
have this what we call a looping problem
so that you study a particular way in
which somebody solves a problem that
gets published it gets out in the public
arena and then the next time you do
those kind of tasks somebody will say oh
that's the kind of task I'll find really
difficult and therefore they find it
difficult and so we have this problem
where because we're studying ourselves
almost there is an inbuilt bias so if
the world out there presents you know
that what I call the Mars Venus hokum
etc we know that the brain will change
as a result of the experiences it has so
if people bring up children differently
however they claim they they don't but
the world will ensure they do those
children will have different experiences
their brains will reflect that so we get
but the bias kind of being reinforced
and I think that's the problem and I
think the other thing just a slightly
different hobby horse is the level of
scientific illiteracy I mean I'm
obviously talking to it you know groups
of converts here but particularly in
this country and in other parts of
Europe people will accept as gospel or
evidence something that a scientist says
because it's been published in a journal
it'll get commented on people read it in
their Sondhi papers or whatever and
people will say well you know the
scientists have said that that's
actually the case and and nobody holds
them to account and I think that's what
feminism should do saying this is biased
maybe accidental maybe as a result of
what we're doing but we need to make
sure people know that there is bias in
there
so are things getting any better you
know is current practice helping are
there things that you commend do you see
a positive story here or is it just same
old same old
it's it's hard actually and it's
interesting to see the antagonism that
actually gets generated
um I belong to an international group
near gendering since the group we're all
sort of neuroscientists interested in
neuroscience from different perspectives
and we do our best to call out
methodological problems where we see
them there was a paper about a month a
couple of months ago
proving that infant brains were
different from birth
so there's publication which was
commented on boys brains different from
girls brains and you know the inevitable
commentary that whatever feminists
because that's always the line feminists
might not like it but my colleagues and
I went through the data we actually
found that this had been Mis analyzed
called out the authors they actually
withdrew you know published in their our
term etcetera but of course that message
is already out there formally enough you
don't get the erratum saying oh by the
way you know we said this in last week's
copy at the zonda time you might get it
but it'd be like right down the bottom
somewhere so that's something which
needs to be done but actually when you
do it then the kind of comments you get
mean we're also known as the feminazis
because you know there's a feeling that
we're like methodological terrorists etc
we're trying to stop people from doing
this research absolutely not we're
saying that this research is so
important it must be done properly
because it's informing so many decisions
right you know from the moment of birth
onwards but it does generate antagonism
among you know in the scientific
community as well as just generally
which slightly concerning mmm and Angela
I mean you're writing the New Scientist
and wired and what's your experience
there and
do you think that the contemporary scene
is moving forward at all on this in some
ways it is moving forward because of the
kind of work that Gino is doing and also
on the gender studies side the kind of
work that Janet is doing but we live in
a very different political environment
now so there are there is a subsection
of people I don't know quite know how
big they are they have they're very
vocal online in reality I don't know how
big they are but they feel able to say
things now that they weren't able to say
10 years ago and they're not just those
crazy you know sexist and racist who you
never you know write green ink letters
to newspapers these are mainstream
scientists working within some of the
best universities in the world who have
very radical ideas on on gender and on
race and now they feel absolutely free
to say what they like because Trump is
in power because the alt-right is there
they feel emboldened so they were always
there and in some ways they were
probably always influencing what was
being published in some small way it's
much easier to see them now and it is
scary because as a layperson even
sometimes as an academic it's difficult
to know what you can trust out there
there are some journals not all journals
are as good as other journals there are
some dodgy journals out there that
published by the big groups like
Elsevier that published NACA Derek Jones
academic journals that publish these
people and and their work is so dodgy it
furthers this idea that we are somehow
fundamentally different I mean it's
central to it all is this notion that
equality is impossible that what we're
trying to do as feminists or as
anti-racist or whatever kind of world we
want is not going to happen
because we're fundamentally different
and that what we see now is the bile you
know the biological reality of the world
that if women aren't represented in
certain groups or certain areas it's
because
we're incapable and is it mainly
biological sciences or neurosciences
there are some disciplines more guilty
of this evolution the evolutionary
psychology and psychology in general I
mean as Janet was saying there was a lot
of bad search in psychology that's been
proven to be bad in neuroscience as well
has it had had its lumps in the past
especially with imaging brain imaging
and reading a little bit too much into
brain scans or maybe even then
speculating based on what you think
those brain scans say so this is a real
problem so I don't think it's bad
science can be corrected and if you have
this element within the academic
community that actually doesn't want it
to be corrected that has an agenda
political agenda to push and doesn't
care whether the science is right or
wrong we need to worry about that
because that's what we saw in the 1920s
and 1930s that led to we've had many
critical problems that we had them for
more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute's of
Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you